time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week beginning
with new concerns over tattoos and
piercings a report out this week from
the American Academy of Pediatrics
provides guidance for doctors young
people and families on potential health
issues surrounding such body
modifications here to break down that
and more as CBS News contributor dr.
Tara Narula Tara give us a sense from a
medical SPECT perspective what were some
of the issues that were brought up well
body modification has been around since
2000 BC and yet we've had surprisingly
little guidance in the medical community
about how to deal with it although it's
increasing in prevalence we know about
20 to 30 percent of our youth and
adolescents report some form of tattoos
or piercing and there are issues so
first and foremost is infection so if
the skin is not cleaned prior to having
this done or after you can get skin
infections and then if the ink or
needles are contaminated you're at risk
for blood-borne infections things like
HIV hepatitis C other issues can include
inflammation or scarring pain bleeding
or hematoma formation and allergic
reactions and then one thing that
adolescents don't often think about is
long-term ramifications so in a recent
survey about 70% of those with tattoos
and piercings report that it hurt their
chances for employment really yes still
yes
they gave some guidelines to
pediatricians to address with young
patients and families with some of those
concerns so the most important thing I
think first was the message that
pediatricians need to deal with this in
a non-critical non-judgmental way
okay need to be aware of the regulations
because they vary from state to state
they should really talk to adolescents
about researching the facilities that
they have this done with in because they
want to make sure that it is reputable
that they practice sterile technique
that they keep their infection control
similar to a doctor's office so they use
new disposable gloves new sterile
needles new ink into new disposable
containers and and that's very important
for preventing infection in addition
they want to make sure the adolescents
are up to date on their immunizations
that they don't take any medications
that could compromise their immunity
educate them on what to look for in
terms of infections afterwards and when
to seek medical care teaching them
things as simple as you know oral
piercings can lead to tooth chipping
down the road
and then the fact that tattoos are
permanent so even though we have lasers
and things I can try to remove them
they're partially effective they are
costly couples of hundreds of dollars
and you require multiple sessions
typically to treat them remember you're
going to have that tattoo when you're 90
as well yes our next topic deals with a
telling survey on the over treatment of
patients more than 2000 physicians
across multiple fields took part in this
survey 46 percent had at least 10 years
of experience a major finding around 20%
of overall medical care was deemed to be
unnecessary so what were some of the top
reasons that they thought this over
treatment is going on this is such an
important issue because it not only
increased costs and cost our country
hundreds of billions of dollars but it
can lead to patient harm and so not
surprisingly at the top of this list was
fear of malpractice so doctors really
practicing defensive medicine one of the
other issues was patient requestor
pressure so many times patients feel
well the more tests I get the better
care I must be getting and so they push
the doctor to get tested on in lab work
and then the third issue really revolved
around difficulty accessing prior
medical records and that happens very
often a patient will come to your office
and say well I had two tests done
recently the doctor can't get access to
the tests and they just reorder it a
reorder something similar and that can
lead to over treatment or over
prescription of testing did the survey
address any possible solutions here well
they talked about starting training for
doctors early so in medical school
really teaching about appropriateness of
testing teaching doctors to practice
evidence-based medicine and guideline
based care and in addition really
addressing this issue again of access to
records and making it easier with data
sharing with electronic medical records
and then one nice thing a couple years
ago that came out was consumer reports
in the American Board of Internal
Medicine published online something
called choosing wisely and this is an
excellent resource for patients they can
go on over 70 specialties have been
involved and really look up different
tests like the PSA or cancer screening
test and see what is this test about do
I need it and really promote a
conversation with their doctor all right
finally diabetics can run the risk of
hypoglycemia while exercising and a
proof-of-concept study researchers at
Binghamton University in New York
demonstrated how a paper-based patch
could help diabetics accurately measure
their glucose levels immediately after
physical activity the patches sensor is
self powered and disposable making it
ideal for working out this is really
really important because you know one of
the biggest barriers for diabetics is
fear of developing hypoglycemia when it
comes to exercise but exercise is so
important for the management of diabetes
prevention of cardiovascular disease so
having something like this that's simple
that doesn't require them bringing
lancets and their glucometer you know or
more expensive cumbersome systems would
be very beneficial it looks just like a
band-aid it's it's a you know I know how
nice really amazed the advancements of
technology helping us live our daily
well dr. taryn Rula thank you very much